hello and welcome to this video I'm
trying to play some glitz games here
from a vacation spot and it's a little
bit different I have my notebook monitor
she's clearly smaller then the one I
have at home
so Adam readjust the whole screen a
state I hope I hope this works out we'll
see my opponent here taking on c4 in
this particular moment it's a little bit
uncommon and it's mostly because um I
get the pawn back now quite easily
here I'd expect him to play c5 are the
most really look very passive it is
trying to get a little bit of grip in
the center yeah what else is there
besides c5 not much yeah some passive
move like c6 yeah but it doesn't really
help him right so I'm just going to
develop yeah expected that I wasn't
quite sure what to do against that
I'll definitely not trade that is out of
the question so probably to e5 you got
more space you don't rate this is one of
the absolute key things to understand in
positional play almost any kind of
closed position is yeah
runs by that rule if you have got less
space straight got more space don't
trade one let's say then if you put this
a little bit more sophisticated you have
to kind of anticipate what the opponent
wants to do and then be ready for attack
here he might want to play at Ft seven
after which I don't want to trade I want
to go back and yeah I'm trying to be
ready for that so I don't want to
hmm allow him to jump to see form in
some cases like here 94 like if he goes
97 I moved the 90s 9 c4 I wanted to stop
that it has some drawbacks of course it
weakens dark squares a little bit and
maybe ya know this is a typical case I
will never trade yeah absolutely not
just God just go back and let him yeah
think about some clever clever way of
using the bishop only aid for example
yeah I didn't think that this was
possible maybe it is possible but it
looks it looks weird okay let's think
about it for a moment I have to move e5
that is definitely possible
the knight has basically no square if he
takes bishop takes this is protected you
know I mean this is at least an
advantage for white may be taking on c5
was good as well very likely it was okay
here if I take f6 he will recapture with
the bishop and then this for persist so
I'll take and now ninety five looks like
the only move the only thing that is a
bit worrisome is that this Bishop on d4
is not not currently defended so if he
moves the knight from the seven it would
be attacked but it didn't it doesn't
really work right okay so what now I can
definitely just capture on d5 the
question is if I want to capture and I
catch up with what is the thing I think
I'll actually do this because the knight
on d5 is just so immensely strong and it
makes Knight b6 stuff like that more
difficult also you can easily imagine
queen g4 leading to a huge attack
and this is what I'm probably playing
now preparing is six for the made on g7
rook 81 things like that of course I'm
very much happy for feedback about the
technical side of things if this is
working working okay I checked some
things I should be audiio but you never
know it's a different kind of setup
yeah honestly I don't see a move what is
he supposed to play the sixes is a
really huge threat
I can still play sex right what is the
answer
I mean I'm threatening mate just mate
yeah I don't see an answer
I mean it's essentially a double attack
the maid on g7 and night is hanging so
the game was I think fairly smooth I
hope the technical side of things also
has been smooth now switching to to the
analysis view of the whole thing I hope
this is also just play correctly I
checked it but you never know so yeah so
we had this this is a fairly uncommon
moment to capture on c4 because if you
want to do that you usually do it here
like yeah well actually you wait until
the white place divorce what I'm trying
to say because now I have a couple of
additional option one is night a3 one is
Queen a4 and one is 95 yes there's Queen
deform that's true
I still thought I have caught Queen a4
check then maybe I'm wrong
yeah maybe 95 isn't all that convincing
24 is definitely better than what he did
that that is quite clear but yeah that's
pretty pretty okay alright so probably
up sorry my 95 to get rid of that my 95
wasn't the most precise usually the
argument is actually queen 8 4 because
in the queen 8 4 lines you usually don't
want to play Bishop e7 you know you have
got a larger emphasis on developing the
Queen side okay but if you look at the
game of here I took on c4 and here c5 is
basically what you have to do you have
to put some pawn in the center and
control some squares at least now d4 is
not possible and that it should be a bit
better for white but nothing special I
would have
plate 93 96 here I'm not sure about I
think that is probably good for white
that should be a good position for one
but he's not really obliged to do that
95 what the engine is mentioning for
example is he could move
yeah I think white is just slightly
better 95 isn't the best move it seems
but he played c6 and this is frankly
just not correct you it doesn't help
that move was just not helping it just
it blunts a little bit this Bishop but I
just have a central advantage so
ninety-seven Knight c3 Knight b6 now
clearly not trading and this is giving
black immediately you have some space
for his pieces so you definitely want to
go back or back as well yeah you want to
avoid the trade I'm not going back with
95 now if you would play like Knight to
d7 like this I would go back 93 would
absolutely never trade and then play a
four and so on
he should have four minor pieces in this
position from my point of view yeah
that's what I want and he would be best
off with no minor piece but if he would
have liked to
it will probably be bearable but before
is too much so Bishop d7 I went Eve form
Bishop e8 yeah c5 you can try but
ultimately I'm not against opening it up
okay Bishop Miege b3 not sure about this
one I wanted to what I wanted to do is I
originally wanted to play Bishop b3 but
if he goes here I want to not right so I
want to go back and then night c4 I felt
was a bit annoying this is why I went b3
I wanted to control this this which
should be three looking at the c5 square
9b d7 yeah
c5 was interesting in for sure but I
should be better Eva was just keeping
the tension and move like Lucas e1 maybe
like this it must be better for one
okay not bd7 of course no trade just go
back and now he tried c5 after which I
think you can take on c5 or play d5 and
5s is quite strong the engine actually
likes 95 even more I know I understand
why because I did not see this more
coming yeah this is very strong and now
95 you cannot stop Knight takes d5
because it's minor pieces are so
misplaced yeah this is fantastic for
wine I think I'm probably also quite
clearly better and after my move but
it's not as convincing this is still
strong but it's not winning immediately
which the other one probably is and now
Knight b6 is stronger he has to fight
against this this strong piece and you
know 97 you suggested by the computer
I'm basically just a pawn up and have
those it's quite quite active
so Bishop e3 was played and now queen g4
should kill him actually for with six
and threats and the engine is giving
plus 3 is 6 and the success is over cute
little point is here if he takes us I
wanted to say human point but I actually
did not see it right here this is this
is not actually working because the
route gets yeah I came yeah okay this
doesn't really matter after Queen g4 I'm
winning yeah I hope this worked alright
please tell me what you thought about
this recording thanks a lot for watching
bye bye